i was stunned when i saw this exchange
last night
i mean wow first saying yeah you know i
haven't gone to europe and now saying
i'm not finished does she know how to
communicate apparently she's been taking
media training i do not think it is
working
i don't see it working either yet kaylee
frankly in that moment that univision
reporter demonstrated
far more poise and strength and an
unflappable quality than our vice
president did and to that end
that's why i'm embarrassed for her as
her constituent for her to literally
lose her mind every time someone asks
what she perceives as a tough question
or dares to interject i know that after
that one debate there were a ton of
t-shirts made
i'm speaking but it just rings frankly
like she's a megalomaniac when she's
doing that in these kinds of interviews
and to go back to our earlier
conversation about how criticism is
framed
let's just read a quote from uh
from an from edward isaac dover who
writes that harris's aides believe that
the republicans
who have attacked her on immigration are
doing so because they're a having
trouble
attacking landing punches on biden also
because harris is a black woman and
because they want to damage her ahead of
an inevitable run for president
biden sees these criticisms in a similar
light i guess it's just not possible
that she is simply
failing at something and the criticism
falls squarely within that
and yes you would think after 18 years
of holding an elected position
she would do better in tough interviews
yeah julian it's interesting so the vice
president staff has apparently
told reporters that they're frustrated
by the questioning thinking that lester
holt's question was grounded in
you know republican criticisms when in
fact it was a fair question but beyond
what they're telling reporters it's
interesting there are white house
officials who have gone on background
saying that they are perplexed they told
cnn this at
the vice president's inability to answer
a question we haven't seen a lot of
leaking out of the biden white house but
it's really fascinating to see this kind
of leaking against the vice president
it is and kaylee i think the best thing
anyone has said about this
all week came from dana a couple of days
ago dana perrino
she said the big picture problem here is
not a pr
issue it's not a communications issue
there's an underlying
policy problem and until the policy
is refined and until the administration
is unified around securing the border
which they appear to not be
messaging is going to remain tricky it's
going to remain
awkward people are going to have to go
on defense because the underlying
reality seems to be that the president
and the vice president are not on the
same page entirely
on this issue they don't agree on
whether or not it's a big deal crisis
and they don't agree on how to address
it that's a policy challenge
so until you get at the root cause here
well no pun intended until you get at
the root cause of the biden
administration's policy
problem you're not going to fix what
we're seeing on tv which is
uncomfortable to watch
yeah dana's exactly right they have a
policy problem a substance problem not a
messaging one
clay even the media is noticing how bad
this trip was i have some headlines
that i want to pop up on the screen we
don't often see criticism like this
from the media but here it is cnn saying
kamala harris's rocky first foreign trip
politico saying former harris aides
foreign trip exposed her political
weakness
in the los angeles times saying harris's
visit to guatemala and mexico
is a mix of diplomacy and controversy
interesting to see the media finally
taking notice
yeah and look the maybe the most
shocking thing about that clip we played
of kamala harris on the second interview
kaylee and you would know this better
than anybody she should have been
prepped
to finally answer this question maybe
she wasn't expecting it when lester holt
caught her unaware and she made that
ridiculous comment about not having been
to europe before
that was a failure she created herself
but when you
have made that error you should expect
to get quizzed on it
and have a perfect response at your
ready i think that's why you're seeing
the administration officials leaking
because i'm sure they prepped her and
then she failed again and the big
picture story here is
they're trying to avoid going to the
border because there isn't a good
answer for why the border is falling
apart and if she goes there
all of the media that might have been
willing to pretend this was not an issue
that it was not a crisis
will get on the airplane they'll fly
there with her and they'll all have to
write stories about what a mess the
border is
so she can't communicate very well and
she's got a looming border crisis that
she's in charge of
this feels like to me a mushroom cloud
that is going to continue to grow
and follow her and i don't think it's
about race at all it's about
incompetence which she has demonstrated
a great deal of over the past several
days
yeah you're right i have no doubt that
her aides prepped her but they have a
problem with their principal who's been
in the public life for quite some time
but still
does not seem to be ready for prime time
tommy all of this comes at a time
when the borders literally on fire 180
000 encounters last month 21-year high
40 000 uh from individuals who are
outside of central america and mexico
that's a four-fold increase since
january
wow they've got a lot on their hands
yeah when kamala says she wants to again
address the root causes or she has to
see the problem of why people are coming
to our border
if you want to address the problem it's
sitting right in front of us it's vice
president kamala harris in the bind
administration and the democrat party as
a whole
we know why people are coming the fact
that democrats still sit back like
they're so shocked and dumbfounded that
people are pouring across our border
is actually amazing to me that they
could sit there and say that with a
straight face they said it
over and over again we're not going to
turn people away people are coming
across the border with biden shirts on
we know exactly what the root causes are
they are the root causes but at the end
of the day instead of just asking when
she is going to go to the border which
quite frankly
i would be surprised if it's any time
soon they have to ask
why are you not going why are you not
going today
what are you doing that is so much more
important than our border than the
sovereignty of our nation that you won't
go
that you won't give us the time that
you're going but why is it that you are
avoiding it it doesn't just need to be
when
it has to be why because then as clay
mentioned the democrats are going to
have to confront the ugly truth
that they don't care that people are
pouring across our border
they don't care that our country is
being invaded they don't care that we're
having a hundred thousands of new people
coming into this country
and it's time that we are just picking
up the pieces from the pandemic they
don't care because it's not a crisis to
them
it's an opportunity but they can't say
that to the american people so for now
it's this dog and pony show but the
question needs to be asked
why kamala why won't you go
she won't go because she's busy securing
faceless cookies to hand out
to the press corps hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now